le mercure s'élève à 45 degrés Celsius
les rivières se vident
l'été 2022 marque Lapierre sécheresse
jamais enregistré en Chine
panique chez les agriculteurs
devant l'urgence le gouvernement chinois
lance une opération insolite
disperser des produits chimiques dans le
ciel pour provoquer la pluie
c'est lancement des nuages
[Musique]
la technique n'est pas nouvelle elle a
été développée en 1946
elle a même été utilisée comme stratégie
militaire pendant la guerre du Vietnam
l’armée américaine tentait d'inonder le
terrain pour bloquer le passage aux
troupes vietnamiennes
aujourd'hui cette pratique controversée
gagne en popularité
les changements climatiques qui sont
pour quelque chose
mais comment parvient-on à modifier la
météo
dans les nuages on retrouve de
minuscules gouttelettes d'eau froide en
suspension trop légère pour tomber ces
gouttelettes doivent fusionner entre
elles pour qu'elles génèrent de la pluie
et c'est là qu'on peut intervenir
en injectant le produit dans les nuages
le plus souvent de l'iodure d'argent
cette structure cristalline qui
ressemble à de la glace attire les fines
gouttelettes d'eau celle-ci fusionne
autour et gel ce qui forme des cristaux
de glace assez lourds pour tomber dans
leur chute ils font la pluie de retour
mais pour que l'opération fonctionne il
faut déjà qu'il y a des nuages
ce n'est pas tout l'idiot d’argent
contenu dans les gouttes de pluie se
répand dans l'environnement et l'argent
est toxique pour les espèces aquatiques
et les micro-organismes
même si les quantités sont très faibles
dans chaque ensemencement le usage
répété sur la même région inquiète les
scientifiques